[Music]
welcome to et live I'm selfish lazy here
today with Andy Grammer what's up who
have a new song for the summer which I
am so excited about thank you
but first I want to ask you about your
fresh eyes video because that's what I
just saw
most recently and it was just so
powerful awesome tell me about the
catalyst for that process for that
project sure so I started as a street
musician I performed on Third Street
Promenade for about four years I've
moved out from New York to here and went
straight there and that's how he like
kind of paid by rent for a while and
there's a lot of homeless people out
there that you just come and come in
contact with and when that's your job
when you're there all day long every day
you kind of move past past just seeing
them as homeless it's like his name's
Dave and he's a homie and so I kind of
that became where my favorite issues to
be a part of so we try to raise
awareness by giving makeovers to people
down at Skid Row which is such a massive
homeless population in Los Angeles yeah
and I love how you hear the song the
first time and it's very obviously a
love song and then somehow it also fits
with this concept it's totally finished
it was unbelievable experience best day
of my year and yeah at the end of the
night I tried to go and sing the songs
acoustically and I couldn't get through
it's the sweetest song to sing to people
I got these fresh I seen you before
actors and it's a bunch of people that
started the day on the street and we're
all made up nude clean totes and stuff
is really sweet you got emotional about
that oh i'm ii get two songs Wow wow
that's incredible and I want to talk
about your new single it's called give
love yes so everyone at home is infratry
because we have a special acoustic
performance that we're going to show you
guys in a little bit yes but to start
let's talk about the inspiration for
that song sure you know I had an
incredible mother about nine years ago
she passed away but I always like to
think that she she gave me so much and
she puts so I feel like she like built a
city in me gave me so much freaking love
that my job now is to go around the
country and just like that's what I do
for a living you just try to make
everybody feel good and I trace it back
to her like packing so much in as I was
growing up so this one's called give
love and it's kind of about how she
taught me all of my life how long did it
take you to write that song I walked out
with a collaboration between two other
guys and
you know you usually get a lot of the
idea out quick and then it takes a while
to get it all the way exactly right
okay that's that's just like nerding out
I'm so exciting to me I love like
hearing about the process yeah all that
stuff what were some of the reactions
from like your family your wife and and
those people close to you when they
heard it for the first time um yeah
everybody's everybody's pretty into it I
think it's also just a good time yeah in
the world to just give some more love
you know just if we need it
something we can all rally around and
you know I played it a couple times live
and just you can see people it just
feels good yeah if it's done correctly
yeah I think that you know as someone
who tries to write songs I'm like that
are the brighter colors you know I find
if you sit down and play a minor chord
on the piano it's infinitely cooler
shines right off the bat but if you do
write with brighter colors it just takes
a little extra work to get it to work
but if you do get it across in a way
it's not cheesy the world really needs
it that's amazing they do we need it we
all have a happy side we absolutely love
to the happy side it's summertime it's
time for fun yeah absolutely so tell us
what else you're working on what else
you've got coming down the pike oh man
I'm just like finished every day is
finishing songs I've written a ton of
songs and now we put the single out and
I'm just in the studio closing let's
hear from New York as well yeah they are
right so one of the most famous closers
on the ink on the Yankees getting
Mariano Rivera Awards person but he's
this homescreen on my phone right now
because I'm just closing like I said
you'd be like you get all these you
write a ton it for me I write a ton of
songs about 106 right now where I'm at
and then oh wow indle it down to about
20 that you know are really really great
and then you go in a studio and you try
to finish them up to where you sell the
first time you're writing it's like
really trying to close it so that's
where I am and then so I knew I was
coming relatively soon okay so circle
back to that's more than 100 songs that
you're over the top of how do you pare
it down I think it's like when the
conversation is not oh man that's a
great song you should hear it
- like of these songs which one would be
a travesty if nobody heard okay that's
just like a better place to come from
yeah I like to throw so many darts at a
dartboard and then like try to decide
over time you see which one
really have honed in on something or
just like on the guitar it won't get out
of your head or yeah you have I was
writing with someone this guy who had
okay who what are you saying if you
write ten songs
you probably think five of them are good
uh-huh right fifty
you probably think two are really good
and if you write a hundred then like one
of them is probably really good as weird
how that works oh my gosh that's crazy
I can't imagine we were talking I'm
super indecisive person so I do not envy
your job if you so are yeah I find out
when you write write when you write it
you would stop if you thought it was bad
so we're writing an app you're like okay
I think this is good it's like a
painting that's like right here and time
allows it to kind of step back a little
bit you go okay cool that's terrible or
that's greater yeah cuz I was going to
ask you like to be real with me are
there some that just belong in the
garbage that they oh my god yeah what a
lot so many yeah yeah how are you don't
know just don't while you're doing it a
lot of times you don't know but that's
why I like to write so many and make
sure that when I get on stage I'm
singing some that I care about or that
needs to be said or that feels like
correct
sure do you have an overarching message
or something that you're trying to say
this time around hmm or just kind of
everything going on in your life it's a
lot of you just kind of as you mature
hopefully you get closer and closer to
being more vulnerable in the correct way
like anytime you are at a show or you're
in a car and a song really really makes
you you're like I love that huh
I think is a couple reasons why that's
my whole study in life is why yeah why
when you're driving you hear song is it
like well I need that sometimes it's
just that it's so freakin hooky that you
just want to hear it again right and
then other times it's a lyric that hits
you that it connects with something
about your the human experience that
you're going through and so I think the
people that are the most vulnerable are
the ones that get even that like bring
up something in other people when they
hear it so that is the ongoing struggle
is how do you be even more and more and
more vulnerable and and still make it
sound good I love about a lot of your
songs they're clearly inspired by family
your wife inspired a lot your mother
hired your most recent and your family
is expanding yeah you got a little one
on the way very soon I have a little
girl coming super-excited about it you
know it's funny I guess
everybody
like if you're not in in the show but in
show business on what if you talk about
it as much as I'm talking about it it's
a fun I don't like interview interview
interview I don't really know I god how
am i I know I but I am just that excited
it's so exciting I think it also helps
that your wife is pretty much the cutest
pregnant baby I'm real cute and real
sassy is she should have her own comedy
show about this pregnancy made her more
sassy yes yes because it's a whole thing
like it's really hard until you actually
go through it as a woman or you're in
close contact with someone's going
through it sure you can't really
understand how intense it is that
everyone comes through this process
everyone has been through everyone had a
mom that did this amount of sacrifice
for them it's really amazing I'm
supremely humbled by what my wife is
going through as they're blowing your
mind right now blowing my mind she gets
up to tea I mean like we'll get in bed
and before both of us fall asleep it'll
be five times she has the city get up
and go back before we even go to sleep
Wow which is like that times a billion
in every single situation it's amazing
that is so women mom I love you chuck
the whole the whole world loves you yeah
so I she had any weird pregnancy
cravings or anything like that
she's gonna be mad that I put her on
blast of this oh you can't eat sugar
she's like super delicate she had a lot
of diet stuff okay so she just ordered
these really lame like vegan
they're like vegan Froot Loops okay and
they're terrible I couldn't tell her
that she had I went tasted him last
night and she's all excited about him
well did she like that yes she did like
him I do oh yes that is very good that's
you score you scored on that one you
look at the bag of beans great now
talking about how excited you are to
have a little girl coming I'm really
genuinely excited I think I've been
reading books and stuff about it and
I've been asking like just before we
started I asked every woman I meet tell
me one thing that your dad did awesome I
think you could have done better yeah
and it seems like the bond of dad and
daughter is a really really special bond
tell me about them because you did ask
me this question off-camera tell me some
of the best responses like have you I
think you've gotten a lot of words of
wisdom problem
lot of words wisdom I also get that it's
probably a pretty hard job because not
everyone it's not every girl just goes
like oh my dad's the best yeah and when
you realize that but a lot of times you
go I'll tell me tell me how your dad and
a lot of them go like mmm interesting I
think about it and we think about how I
am is like oh man I do not want my
daughter Oh 30 years I really I really
want to take it very seriously and I
really want to be someone that her eyes
light up when she would someone answer
that question I think you're well on
your way I really don't know any right
now and so I'm very excited about it
though that's amazing so have you chosen
a name yet we have my wife says I can't
tell anyone okay I would say right now I
have no problem well don't you find I
find that a lot of times once you tell a
name not that I have kids but I've heard
that when you tell a name everybody has
something they associated all totally
yeah but I think you're strong enough in
your name like I don't care what anybody
excited about it then it doesn't matter
oh good has she inspired any new music
already yeah I got some songs on this
next album my third album that will
definitely be about this little girl and
just a process yeah you know watching
your wife get pregnant
one of my favorite things to ask
musicians I was actually just asking
somebody this last week is what music
are you forcing her to listen to in the
womb because I know that's important to
you guys right I would to get them
exposed early what is she listening to
so it's really funny because we're both
my wife is a songwriter as well and a
lot of music I listen to music I love my
job and listen to music but a lot of
times I listen to like the radio or pop
music my brain goes into understanding
why it's working and it's hard to relax
okay
I find that jazz is above my paygrade I
don't understand it anyway so it's just
sweet right so like old jazz singers a
lot of what we listen to right now we
start every morning I just turn on like
the the jazz - jazz playlist that I made
and I literally take the phone and just
like put it on her stomach so she's
going to come out like soloing I was
going to say I think this is going to be
like the coolest baby yeah she should be
pretty cool yeah just right off the bat
I'm looking at my phone because we've
got fan comments and grasshoppers coming
in flores's give love what a great
message
Thank You Connie says Andy are my
favorite singer in the whole world we
love you in our household
nice Matthew says love your music when
are you releasing your album you said
soon can you give us any more than that
soon um it's just got to be great guys
alright I'm - I I really I don't want to
put anything up we we got the single out
and I promise as soon as it's great and
that's not that long we're not that far
away okay and basically to me I spend
most of my time on the writing of it and
I've got the songs now I just got to go
in and wrestle them down to be exactly
how I want you to hear yes okay a few
more here Rose says I love your love for
your mother thank you I remember that's
why you did Dancing with the Stars which
you rocked by the way oh my god that was
so hard do you miss those days
no no not really fun but I don't miss
that crazy right the hardest thing I've
ever done
Wow Jasmine says we're living in such
dark times what's the best way to give
love every day hmm
great question jasmine yeah the best way
to give love I think it's that um it's
it's it's not one size fits all it's
like what do you have to offer that's
the best my my dad was it singers well I
actually I forget was my dad my mom nice
tell me about this story I don't know if
this is even true but I'll tell you the
story that Bono who's apparently a big
philanthropist was like making well
somewhere in some African country and
you really wanted to get his hands dirty
so he went in and was like digging the
wells with these with these Africans and
he apparently was very good at it so
they stop there they're like hey cool
cool thank you for for helping us dig
what we could really use is like some
songs to help us while we while we do
this and I think that's such a great
story so find what do you have to offer
and and do that super great yeah that's
such a good I think life lessons online
or beyond oh let's just go with that
yeah that's a pretty great story now I
want to see your performance of get
level I actually got to see it be taped
live it's so good you guys so we really
want to show it to you can we roll it
now are we ready all right take a look
all right
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you say you're gonna be alive in a cold
you got it to love from hit up a
homemade people feeling down my people
here at the ayatollahs good enough I
gotta give hey honey what you talking to
honey pig
oh definitely
our days but I go babies we'll see you
should I give loved all my people all my
people Mila kiss my I give all my please
all my people Nina give some packing all
my bleep on my feet feeling every day
[Music]
[Music]
all my people my people my people how
fun is that a very funny thing to out in
public as well like if you're like it
when I hear music you just kind of like
you rock to it that's a little bit weird
to rock to yourself and well I don't
know it just like a strange thing in the
room that cool that's cool of a
psychologist recognized I was going to
ask how it is watching yourself what I
loved about watching that is seeing just
the pure joy on your face sure you can
tell how much you love it yeah yeah
hopefully I comes across that's good
absolutely so how much fun is that so
yeah really fun
Oh to watch myself oh it's my cells okay
getting music that music is is the best
yes yes oh I want to take a couple more
fan questions before I let you go a few
more have been coming in Reggie says
congrats to you and your wife thank you
so much Sarah just putting you right on
the spot here do you want more kids
oh man I'm sure I do one more kids we'll
see what's for let's get through this
yeah big thing this is a first run
exactly we'll see how I get through it
and see well you're my wife down for
another one yep that's a big question is
the wife okay with those right yeah
Chris says no the baby is
but will there be a new tour soon of
course probably right around whenever
the album is yeah just we'll get it to
her I mean we're going to tour Australia
in October which is really cool fine and
I hopefully something after that you can
bring the baby on the road yeah yeah
sure baby
love it that's ever hahahah and a sweet
comment from Miranda she says your music
gets me through life ah thank you that
makes me really happy I won't hear it oh
I love this question actually that just
came in from Danielle she says will you
be a strict dad or a fun Disneyland dad
who's going to be the good cop and the
bad cop when it comes to you and your
wife like real non-russians real talk
yeah um I think I'm fun but you know
it's funny like I initially started that
I I sent out an email to a couple women
that I really loved in my life and would
ask this question uh what one good thing
when bad thing and I specifically said
it's a small group because I'm like I
really like you guys how you turned out
I'm wondering what what your dad did and
they all said one thing that was good
and then their bad thing was like my dad
was really strict but that was so
similar in all of them and I love them
so I don't know if you gave me that I
think I might have gotten some just just
by doing the research a strict dad might
be good who knows yeah maybe they didn't
intend to go with a vengeance all about
yeah that's like one of the things I
took from it very cool well
congratulations to you everyone which is
exciting - thank you for coming in
reshoot it
thank you all for watching we can
continue the conversation on social
media over on Twitter I'm at so visual
AC
you're at and erm yes but first don't
forget to like our Facebook page where
Entertainment Tonight thank you so much
for watching ET live we'll see you next
time
you